[Music]
all right Keesha emotional eviction when
did you make that decision that you're
gonna make that plea send me home
honestly it happened today over the past
like I was ready to stay and fight but
my breast milk supply has kind of been
getting a little little
less and they asked me honestly and I
look like you know to tell you the truth
since you guys put me up from the block
anyway it's time for me to go home it's
time for me to make sure that Ella is
okay because she is my priority I'm not
gonna lie like anyone who's like Oh
250,000 nah you know of course people
want to win but her and making sure that
she's okay and has what she needs is
priceless and what did it mean to you to
see your fellow houseguests vote
unanimously in your favor against your
favor however you want to see it you
know honestly I was so grateful and so
appreciative and one thing I prided
myself on my entire Big Brother journey
was to be very genuine and authentic
transparent and honest and I really
tried my best actually I really did that
I was very upfront with everybody and
I'm grateful that they recognized that I
was being so honest and so sincere and I
really just needed to ensure that she
was getting the nutrition she needed
I know viewers are gonna be sad to see
blackroll magic already busted up no
black role magic will never be busted up
it lives on but I was really excited to
you know be able to meet someone who I
had such a very different perspective of
and get to know her heart and get to see
a very different side of her so she's
gonna carry I told her I said you gotta
you gotta got a handle it for me I can't
be here I'll be there in spirit but make
me proud you now get to go home to your
little girl Ella what is the first thing
you're gonna do when you see her again
and just give her the biggest hug in the
case imaginable and I just can't wait to
hold her in my arms all night and we'll
have she can have mini booby snacks as
long and as often as she desires that's
what we called them booby snacks so
booby snacks all day for Ella all day
but any regrets about this experience I
have no regrets
I'm really proud of myself for really
getting in there I'm very proud of
myself for maintaining my integrity but
I stuck with that and didn't allow the
chaos and the changing dynamic and all
of the personalities and you know the
paranoia to take me from my Center and I
trusted my intuition
[Music]